jordan when you're going through that
phase
normally for a person to come out of a
place we are that we've never been
before we need some kind of a source of
inspiration right so
yeah and and we like to find someone to
say well that's my hero like i have a
painting in my office called dead
mentors it's me in the painting with
eight other characters
in a vault we're having a conversation
it's a debate between two books
communist manifesto and atlas shrug so
it's a discourse they're having a debate
they have in a discourse it's very
interesting characters
but you can tap into somebody you're
like okay i can tackle who are the
characters who are the characters in the
painting
let me i just moved to florida so so i
got john f kennedy
i got einstein i got the chaviron
lincoln mlk tupac ironton senna
uh milton friedman and uh
one other character i'm forgetting great
so so that's so good because look
and you can surround yourself with these
these great minds and and you can you
can
you can you can what would you say in
some sense you can choose them as your
peers
voluntarily dead or not right it's a
form of ancestor worship in some sense
and i mean that
in the most i mean that in the deep
sense and
you can do that's one of the advantages
of that is education as far as i'm
concerned is
pick your peers and and yeah and this
instinct we have to find someone to
admire
that's the deepest of religious
instincts and it's unbelievably deep in
human beings
and you know and and we have this
mimicry this capacity for mimicry that's
that's
an integral part of our cognitive
architecture and uh
it's the precursor to thought and we do
identify
you know you notice you notice you
admire someone that is the instinct
to mimic because to admire is then to
want to be that and that's the action of
the moral instinct
it finds a target in the world and says
well i could be like that
but at first it says this person is
attractive or this person is compelling
it grabs you
it grabs you and that's the instinct for
further developments very positive thing
it can be a very positive thing who'd
you tap into
was it a biblical figure was it a
philosopher was it a leader
was it a political leader when you were
going through your moment the last 12
months who were you saying at least
he overcame it i can here's what he went
through was worse here's what
was there anybody you would go to well
there has been throughout my life
all sorts of of intellectual figures
figures from my own life as well i found
many things about my father
extremely admirable and and still do
my mother as well and so i was fortunate
to have people in my immediate
environment who
played that role for me and that that's
a huge gift
i have all sorts of intellectual idols
um
i would say and there are people whose
work i've read deeply and that's been
extremely useful to me
um and then that shades into the
consideration of religious figures at
at some point um so and i've spent a lot
of time
studying religious thinking and trying
to i mean what religious thinking is
in some sense is the collective attempt
to specify the ideal for
for mimicry so imagine that imagine that
uh
you know you you have those eight
figures in your painting
so imagine there's something about each
of those people that you found
compelling and admirable
so then imagine that you could abstract
out from that
what was compelling and admirable and
make one person out of that that was
sort of the union of all those eight it
was
everything good about those eight people
brought into one
person well that's that's approaching a
divine figure
and and and when you hear christian
statements for example like christ is
the king of kings
that actually means something technical
from a psychological perspective
what it means is that and i'm not
speaking in religious terms here
precisely although it shades into the
religious is that
a religious ideal is in fact
the abstracted representation of what is
admirable
as such and it's a it's extremely
useful to have that made into an
abstraction to some degree too because
it also means that you then have
something that you're responsible to
so let's say you and you've done this
with your painting
you have these eight people who you're
now um
what what would you say you're
responsible to them you're accountable
to them
you're accountable to their spirit and
so
now your conscience can speak with their
collective voice and it can tell you
when you're less than you could be
and then you can use that to guide you
to manifest that spirit that's
embodied in those eight people and
that's a pathway to further growth
and and it's something that we're we're
hypothetically in all of our
conversations when we're demanding
from one another that we respond
properly we're trying to evoke that
ideal from
ourselves and from other people we're
constantly doing that
that's partly why i love podcasts
because that can really happen in real
time
like i just released a conversation with
jocko willing today where i think that
happened
for much of the conversation and
you know as i get healthier i'm hoping
that will work better
and to the degree that we're doing the
right thing at the moment you know we're
doing our best to manifest that
abstracted ideal and the other thing
that's so
remarkable about that is that as long as
we do it the better we do it the more
compelling we're going to find the
conversation the time will disappear
will get absorbed into the conversation
and we'll walk away thinking i don't
know what was happening but that was
worth doing
and and you get that you get
there as far as i'm concerned you get
there with
with truth that's the pathway
spoken truth jordan who who are those
names you said mom dad who else are some
of those names
that you uh you go to well you and carl
jung was an unbelievably
profound influence on me almost all the
major psychotherapists i read them
deeply carl rogers was real useful to me
abraham maslow freud i read a lot of
freud
uh and then there's alexander schulze
nitchen was a huge
influence friedrich nietzsche i read
most of his major works when i was young
and then a large number of scientists
jeffrey gray
who's a neuroscientist i i
i what would you say clawed my way
through his work which is very very
dense
it was extremely useful he was a good
model as a scientist
my mentor at mcgill robert peel was
someone who who taught me a lot about
administration and about
uh giving credit where credit is due and
being comfortable in your own domain of
competence like bob
who i am still in regular contact with
bob and i had different skills
and he was able to value my skills
without ever feeling intimidated
and and i could do the same with his
skills and that made our partnership
extremely productive and so that was
very useful so if you like this sort of
shortcut from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye